like a high-end exotic sports car the
Chromebook pixel is blazing fast
expertly designed lovingly built to
highly priced for most sane people it
runs on Google's Chrome OS which is
essentially just the Chrome browser with
the desktop wallpaper and the ability to
download offline functionality for some
web apps the nearly 13 inch gorilla
glass displays the pixels marquee
feature it's gorgeous impacted with more
than 4 million pixels which is more than
any other laptop out there it's also a
touchscreen which makes navigating
around the web a lot more fun and
despite the screen being glossy
fingerprints rarely show up the glass
touchpad and the black keyboard are
among the best of ever used ports are
kept to a minimum and there's no DVD
Drive all the screws on the pixel are
hidden and the gunmetal gray aluminum
body is plain badass the hardware is
among the best you can get on any laptop
but with an operating system that is
basically just a browser and a price tag
that's as high as 1450 dollars don't
expect to see too many pixels at your
local coffee shop after all you don't
see too many Lamborghinis driving down
the street